lohnt sich arbeiten noch so wie es die
Spitzen der Ampel immer wieder
betonen arbeit muss sich lohnen Respekt
für Arbeit mit dem Bürgergeld lohnt sich
Arbeit mehr stimmt das für
bürgergeldempfänger gibt es auch dieses
Jahr 12% mehr das zweite Jahr inf Folge
bedeutet für einen Single im Monat ca
1221 € vom Amt für ein paar mit zwei
Kindern rund 3200 79€ netto ohne Arbeit
ungerecht sei das so die Union die vor
anderthalb Jahren noch für das
Bürgergeld gestimmt hatte nun aber will
sie es
abschaffen es gibt sehr viele Studien
mittlerweile dass es nicht nur
Einzelfälle sind sondern sehr viele
Fälle dass Menschen sagen sie gehen
arbeiten aber am Ende des Tages bleibt
mir nicht mehr als wenn ich Bürgergeld
erhalte und das macht natürlich was mit
einer Gesellschaft und deswegen müssen
wir das ganze System ändern das
Bürgergeld gehört in dieser Form
abgeschafft das Bürgergeld mehr fördern
statt fordern so das Ziel der Ampel ganz
wichtig die Betroffenen mit den
Jobcentern auf Augenhöhe die SPD wollte
ihr Harz 4 Trauma überwinden doch nach
einem Jahr spricht der zuständige
Minister plötzlich wieder von Sanktionen
und totalverweigerern seine Genossen
entsetzt wenn wir über Totalverweigerer
reden wer ist das denn überhaupt und im
Gesetzesentwurf ist es aktuell so dass
wenn man das erste konkrete Jobangebot
schon ausschlägt eben diese Sanktion
greift und das kann ja wohl keine
komplettverweigerung sein wir brauchen
da eine Rechtssicherheit für die
Menschen wie oft dürfen sie denn nein
sagen bevor ihnen sowas droht ich meine
wir sprechen ja auch von wirklich extrem
existentiellen Nöten die sowas auslöst
so wie es ist kann es auf jeden Fall
nicht durch den Bundestag gehen das
Bürgergeld soll einen menschenwürdiges
Existenzminimum sichern für derzeit rund
4 Millionen
erwerbsfähige davon gehen ca 800.000
einer Tätigkeit nach sogenannte
Aufstocker rund 700.000 neben an einer
Qualifizierung Teil bleiben 2,6
Millionen die nicht arbeiten die der
Minister im Visier hat für einige will
er wie früher den Druck erhöhen
Sanktionen in der Grundsicherung erhöhen
die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass Menschen
Jobs aufnehmen und das gilt sowohl für
die die tatsächlich sanktioniert wurden
als auch für die bei denen das nicht der
Fall ist weil Sanktionen eben auch schon
verhalten dann anpassen lassen wenn es
noch gar nicht zu einer Sanktion
gekommen ist einfach um eine Sanktion zu
vermeiden seit Einführung des
Bürgergelds durften Jobcenter maximal
30% der Leistung streichen die Ampel
begründete das mit einem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts aus 2019 darin
hieß es aber auch wird eine solche
tatsächliche existenzsichernde zumutbare
Erwerbstätigkeit ohne wichtigen Grund
verweigert ist ein vollständiger
leistungsentzug zu
rechtfertigen mit diesem Passus
begründet Heil nun seine Rolle rückwärts
zum Ärger vieler Sozialpolitiker
97% der Menschen die im Bürgergeld sind
kommen nie mit irgendeiner Sanktion in
Kontakt weil sie mitmachen weil sie
arbeiten wollen darauf haben wir uns
konzentriert im Bürgergeld und dieser
Fokus auf diese Menschen der bleibt auch
künftig Wissenschaftler machen eine
andere Rechnung auf von den rund 800.000
bürgergeldbeziehern die zusätzlich
arbeiten gehen
66% einer Teilzeittätigkeit nach
lediglich 11% Arbeiten vollgrund es
lohnt sich nicht die Abzüge sind zu hoch
der typische Fall des aufstockers ist
nicht derjenige der vollarbeitet und
weil er so wenig verdient dann noch eine
Aufstockung vom Amt braucht sondern der
typische Fall ist ein Leistungsempfänger
der sich mit einem Minijob in geringem
Umfang etwas dazu verdient und das
System ist falsch und das müssen wir
ändern ist die Ampel falsch abgebogen
setzt das Bürgergeld verkehrte Anreize
die Koalition wieder auf der Suche nach
dem richtigen
Maß ich begrüße bei uns im Studio den
Bundesarbeitsminister Hubertus hi schön
guten Abend und frohes neues Jahr noch
das wünsche ich Ihnen auch he guten
Abend sie haben dem Kabinett
vorgeschlagen dass
sogenannte Totalverweigerer Menschen die
erwerbsfähig sind aber nicht arbeiten
wollen mit zwei monatsbezügen Entzug
gedroht werden muss bzw sie wollen das
auch durchziehen seit über einem Jahr
tobt im Land die Diskussion darüber ob
sich das Arbeiten überhaupt noch lohnt
aufgrund des neuen Bürgergelds ist die
Idee mit den sogenannten
totalverweigeren da mehr als ein
Ablenkungsmanöver von ihnen ja muss
erstmal sehen was der Sinn des
Bürgergelds ist es geht um zweilei es
geht darum Menschen die notgeraten sind
verlässlich abzusichern und gleichzeitig
Menschen wo immer es geht die
erwerbsfähig sind in Arbeit zu bringen
und die allermeist das ist ja in dem
Beitrag auch deutlich geworden da gibt's
gar kein Dissens die davon betroffen
sind arbeiten konstruktiv mit das heißt
wir reden über eine sehr kleine Gruppe
von Menschen die total Verweigerer sind
die wiederholt zumutbare Arbeit
ausschlagen und da sagen wir da wollen
wir ein deutliches Zeichen setzen denn
das ist kein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen wir brauchen
Mitwirkungspflichten aber wir brauchen
vor allen Chancen von Menschen in Arbeit
zu kommen und darum geht's dann geht es
also um Gerechtigkeit in dieser Sache
Sie möchten dass Leute die Geld
empfangen auch tatsächlich dafür
arbeiten und finden es ungerecht wenn
Steuerzahler für diese Menschen
aufkommen obwohl sie eigentlich
arbeitsfähig wären ja es geht auch um
Gerechtigkeit aber es geht vor allen
Dingen darum dass wir in Deutschland in
der Debatte mal aus den Schützengräben
rauskommen es ist vollkommen falsch alle
Menschen die im Bürgergeld sind unter
den Generalverdacht zu stellen dass sie
faul sind das war immer ungerecht das
ist auch nicht in Ordnung es geht ja z.B
um alleinerziehende Frauen auch um
Menschen mit Einschränkung die eine
Chance brauchen wieder in Arbeit zu
kommen und das sind die aller
allermeisten und da setzt das Bürgergeld
an z.B mit der Chance zur Qualifizierung
aber ich sage auch dass dass diejenigen
die wiederholt zumutbare Arbeit aus ohne
Grund ablehnen nicht damit rechnen
können dass das auf Verständnis trifft
weder beim sozialstad noch in der
Bevölkerung und deshalb hat das
Verfassungsgericht sie haben es im
Beitrag ja erwähnt ausdrücklich gesagt
dass in diesen Fällen wie gesagt eine
begrenzte Zahl wahrscheinlich im
niedrigen einstelligen Prozentbereich
wir dieses Zeichen auch setzen können
und sollten und ich glaube dass ist ein
beitracht dazu leisten wird diese
Debatte auch endlich zu versachlichen es
geht also um Gerechtigkeit es geht auch
ein bisschen um schreckung die CSU
fordert in ihrem jüngsten Papier wenn
sanktionieren dann richtig also Bezüge
streichen bis der oder diejenige
tatsächlich arbeiten geht warum nicht
gleich diese Konsequenz weil wir uns an
das Urteil des Verfassungsgerichts unter
anderem zu halten haben es geht um
Existenzminimum es geht darum dass
Menschen die notgeraten sind abgesichert
sind verlässlich und dass wir schon
heute auch Mitwirkungspflichten haben
ist ja bekannt im Gegensatz zu dem was
die CSU der die übrigens dem Bürgergeld
damals zugestimmt haben immer so
erzählen das heißt wir reden hier nicht
über terminversäumnisse da gibt's die
Möglichkeit auch für Leistungsminderung
sondern wir reden über die Menschen die
kleine Gruppe von Menschen die total
Verweigerer sind und ich finde dass
diese Minderheit von Menschen weder das
System in Verruf beraten lassen darf
noch die Menschen übrigens die
Bürgergeld sich redlich anstrengen und
bemühen aus ihrer Not rauszukommen es
geht um Gerechtigkeit um Solidarität
aber eben auch um Eigenverantwortung und
trotzdem haben sie ja ein Problem mit
der Vermittlung in ihren eigenen rein
wir haben die Abgeordnete Klose gesehen
die Jos werfen ihnen vor Menschen
hungern zu lassen um sie zu bestrafen
wie wahrscheinlich ist es dass ihr
Vorschlag in den ein eigenen Reihen
durchgeht wir haben uns in der Koalition
darauf verständigt auch in der
Bundesregierung und es ist ja nicht nur
Teil des Haushaltskompromiss sondern ist
auch notwendig und sinnvoll und ich sehe
dass wir größere Teile der Bevölkerung
und auch die allermeisten abgeorden
meiner Partei dahinter haben und es gibt
gute Argumente die habe ich eben genannt
das wird niemand alleine gelassen an
dieser Stelle sondern es geht um
Eigenverantwortung ich mach's einem
praktischen Beispiel da gerät jemand in
Not und braucht Unterstützung des
Staates die kriegt dieser Mensch das das
ist ein Gebot des Sozialstaates aber wir
reden über die kleine hartnäckige Gruppe
die tatsächlich jede Form von zumutbarer
Arbeit ausschlägt und das ist nicht zu
akzeptieren deshalb ist die Wissenschaft
das ja auch gesagt hat das notwendiges
Signal für die meisten Bezieher von
Bürgergeld ist es allerdings so dass es
sich nicht lohnt aus einem Teilzeitjob
in Vollzeit zu gehen einfach weil die
Bezüge entsprechend so stark gekürzt
werden dass man dafür nicht 20 oder 30
Stunden mehr in der Woche arbeiten
möchte die Wissenschaft sagt ganz klar
hier liegt ein wahnsinniges Potenzial
wirklich mehr Menschen in Arbeit zu
bringen sie haben das auch versprochen
dass das passiert wann passiert es also
erstmal müssen wir sagen dass Arbeit
immer ein Unterschied macht und Arbeit
sich lohnt da gab es ja auch eine
schräge Debatte denn klar ist wir haben
Zuverdienstmöglichkeiten im Bürgergeld
ja schon verbessert wir haben den
Mindestlohn erhöht übrigens zum Thema
immer noch sehr wenig übrig Thema
Lohnabstand will ich aber einen klaren
Satz sagen seit 2015 ist der Mindestlohn
stärker gestiegen nämlich um 46% als der
grundsierungssatz der ist um 41% gesoren
es gibt also ein Lohnabstand worüber we
wir jetzt reden ist die Frage wie lohnt
sich Arbeit mehr wie kriegt man den
Abstand vergrößert und da finde ich es
richtig dass wir nicht nur bei der Frage
von Zuverdienstmöglichkeiten die wir
schon erweitert haben ansetzen sondern
wer Lohnabstand will der muss für
gerechtere Löhne streiten der
windestlohn wird sich weiterentwickeln
und wir werden übrigens dafür sorgen
dass es mehr Tariflöhne in Deutschland
gibt das macht ein Unterschied indem wir
z.B dafür sorgen dass öffentliche
Aufträge des Bundes nur an die
Unternehmen gehen die auch nach Tarif
bezahlen vielen Dank Herr Heil der
Bundesarbeitsminister verspricht uns
dass es mehr Menschen geben wird die
mehr in Arbeit
kommen